um I have one apology which is councilor
Bond
assume there are no others
moved thank you see you thank you very
much
um any Declarations of interest that we
don't already have recorded
there being none we just move on we have
a public 400 day counselors so we have a
couple of speakers coming forward
um and for those that are going to speak
just to explain the process
um five minutes per speaker
so if you have two it'll be 10 minutes
um I'm reasonably flexible on the time
I'm not going to hold you to the exact
moment be mindful that councils may well
want to ask you questions after you've
presented so allowing some time for that
would be great
so after first public forum speaker
would like to come forward that'll be
great
um
I'm here today along with all my um
whanau and colleagues around the
discussion it is all off to the table
sure
I am a ratepayer
I am a ratepayer I am a mother
I am a wife and I'm here
I also am Maori I'm a nurse and I'm here
today because I want to make sure that
I'm born and raised and I have a voice
in our community
foreign
we have so many struggles but we stand
in the light of our tupuna being Maori
is because of our whakapapa we do not
choose to be Maori we choose to be not
to be racist no unconscious bias and no
institutionalized racism racism or
interpersonal racism
but that is a choice we choose not to do
but being Maori is not a choice it is
our Papa that brings us here
today
Moana Jackson again talks about the
struggles that we have
for all of us we descend in the light of
our ancestors of our tupuna
we people will not remember us for the
things we do or the things we say they
remember us for how we feel
Kia Ora
um
foreign
nothing wrong with that as far as I know
however
these things like um
we have too much to say or or you know I
don't know where that comes from
to me I don't took it away in here our
two print over here
you know I'm an Irish Maori I'm proud of
both heritage
I'm proud of this place I'm a black boy
uh Chatham Island Boy
and uh and I was born on the ocean
and Christchurch is coming to Bluff
so they had the registry of Christchurch
that's why I'm a crusader fan as well
but anyway besides that
are Maori and uh and everything that we
do
everything that we do on them right is
is Paramount for us as a people
we learned English
okay we had to learn English because we
were told to
in our schools we're not asking you to
learn to know Maori
we're not telling you to live to the
Almighty
we're telling you how do you say things
like
we must be pretty pissed off because
there's a whole lot of places down here
at night and today on Maori namely in
this in this Moody hickey
even Rudy hickey
I mean for God's sake why hope I
what is your problem
why do you beg us
why do you give us a hard time because
we're Maori we're not anymore we're
motherfinner of this area
why are we man offender because we're
here before you
long time ago
I just think you need just to wake up a
little bit
shake your heads and think about it a
little bit and then I've already sat
down and never takes a few discounts are
here to come to them right never cut it
all
which would probably happen hopefully I
don't see why not
you know be really good to put your uh
to put your foot on the uh on on the on
the Farina
and walk through that putty and come in
and sit down and have a cup of tea after
we have our argument
I mean I'm not going to feed you before
that that's for sure but anyway
our sole purposes here is not that is
for you guys of uh you know especially
down here naito people
now people stand proud until I was with
the meeting this morning with our
co-mata if they were here you'd know
what I mean about strong wahine
because they'd be all up talking and I'm
sorry Nobby you wouldn't even be able to
stop shut them up
telling you now but anyway besides that
I'm here I'm part of this group here and
a whole lot of us here
to say to you guys that no enough's
enough
don't cause divisions between the town
do not close your visions
you know that is just the wrong wrong
thing to do
we need to be one
a people all one here in whitihiki
um
iwi
call Tony biddlewa
I've been asked in the last five minutes
10 minutes to speak on behalf of my
whanau
Maori whanau part of our community your
community the community that you serve
at this table
and so today I would like to speak to a
notice of motion that has been put up by
Amir
that is awful
it is said
it is very sad today that we have to
come here to have this Corridor with you
when I read the notice of motion
I felt
real sense of aroha and sadness I
thought about my father who was born
apetihama Biddle that was the birth name
that he was given but no one could
pronounce it so you know what they did
they took it away from him and they
called him Bruce
and he had that name for the rest of his
life until I received his birth
certificate when he passed at the age 80
and learned that his name was aperiyama
Biddle
and you today have a decision to make
whether you take
how to deal away
by choice you are taking the choice from
us
bilingual names on buildings is not
satisfactory if the council wants to
name a building until Maori they should
be allowed to you should be allowed to
and we shouldn't have to come and fight
here for that
not today don't ever
this is divisive to our community
as a previous epidemia and a counselor
who was set in this room I am absolutely
disgusted
I'm shaking
I'm angry and I'm completely sad and
each and every one of you please look at
me when I speak to you don't look away
don't look away at me
I know that you are good people I know
you're here trying to do the best don't
divide our city please don't divide our
city turn this notice of motion down and
let the normal process continue as it is
it's unnecessary it's unreasonable and
you're only gonna cause more division
for our people who are going through
enough already
racist undertones races undertones from
counselors from Mayors from Governors
from leaders is unacceptable in our
community
we are not one people we think
differently
we have different values we have
different people we have different ways
of processing things
please elected members I am asking you
today please do the right thing and vote
against this motion
oh
all right
um
but then they people
put it back in pick a court attack
um
thank you
the fortunate thing about very fortunate
thing about our people down here in the
south is that we are very
lucky and fortunate have such strong
manawahine amongst us that are able to
um to voice
in eloquence
um their thoughts and um I'm just
before us and just say yeah we're we're
very disappointed in the uh the approach
being taken by the notice of motion
pinned by the mere by his worship and
the reasons being is that it feels like
it's a paper that hasn't had input from
ewi
um your partners and that's why I stand
as your partner to say whereas
um
where is the partnership there seems to
be division amongst us and we're deeply
concerned about that
so
I do wish to speak to the notice of
motion for the council to adopt
bilingual approach to any naming of the
Civic building it is hard to understand
why a community or its members of the
community are concerned about an
uncoordinated approach to the naming of
Civic buildings
bullet point number one talks about some
buildings having an unequal focus on to
deal
um I'm not sure Community concerns
highlighted by an unequal focus on tadil
I'm just looking at some of our
buildings around town and I look at here
wakatuia it's a beautiful name and it
talks about emphasizing the value of
unity and also turn to another a name
that was brought up more recently called
and it's also a name that's used for
Unity Unity around things and processes
that we have within the wider Ultra
context we're going to do things
together to make things safe
and that's what um we talk about when we
talk about a Waka we're doing things
we're rowing our Walker together it's
not about division
Point number two is
um that some naming has initial naming
to deal which creates confusion there is
no confusion no down to real Maori names
initially coming first our children in
our schools our children and our schools
and Coulda can testify to this there is
they understand the uniqueness of
languages and Maori and English
languages they don't have a biased our
children don't have a bias going through
schools we learn about Maori and we
learn about English and there is no
confusion for our youngsters so let them
bear an example for us
that some material names are not related
to the nature of the building or what
service it provides to the community
example
is ill pot in English
the real names Beauty
real names beautifully described uses of
buildings and their place on landscape
hinaki is as an example
the place of plenty a place of resources
a place for well-being of people and I
can see the the Beauty and the way that
we poetically describe
um these
why these names are brought to the
attention and some people and I read in
the paper that they're gifted they
wouldn't be gifted unless it's a real
um understanding that um everyone agrees
that they really are going to serve
their purpose for our Civic buildings
and um I look at
when the gifting of names
um
they are they are discussed previously
with all the parties being names are
gifted we wouldn't want to get a give
give gift a name that's thrown us right
back at us it's uh it's Unity it's
talking about things together and why we
um gift names and give them names is not
done lightly it's not done lightly
there's a lot of reflection a lot of
thought and um that's the reason we give
names to help support our relationship
our partnership
the recommendation process I think
without repeating them all too much I
believe that the recommendation process
all the bullet points
they need to be redone they need to be
done in partnership with your ewe
Partners
um I had
gone through the whole lock and then
said well they need to be worked on they
need to be worked on together and I
um
totally disagree with the bullet point
that says that Council does not approve
metaphorical names in to deal
that means names that denote something
not relative relevant to buildings or
service provided example hinaki for the
Civic building and the reason I totally
disagree is that we have to look at our
national museum
so there's a fine examples of the use of
Maori language to denote such a
beautiful building and iconic a
nationally important building which is
uh te Papa
and when I look at the bilingual name
displays
I think it's a case of
bilingual displays are a bit of an art
and you lead those sorts of the way that
they are
um interpreted and the way that they're
designed to The Experts and they need to
be designed with their Partners when
they they are
they are partner signs
so
I'm not concerned I'm really concerned
about why our language is now being put
second we are First Nations people the
language of um Maori has been heard for
800 years on this landscape we are not
new to this landscape and therefore I do
not understand why having names first
and seconds in Maori would naturally
come first as as being the first
language on this Earth
um I'm also extremely concerned about
some of the recent statements made by
his worship at previous Hui regarding
Maori and Erie relationships I implore
the council to seek ewe your partner's
advice before proceeding therefore not
adopting a biased opinion in regards
this topic
quarter Coast I thank you for hearing me
so Christians counselors
oh sorry Lizzy
curadain yeah
thank you very much for what you had
said
Dean I wanted to ask you a question
as well as the notice of motion in the
agenda today
there is
just past that notice of motion
a guidelines paper on bilingual signage
guidelines from teponokoturi
if the proposal today had been that this
Council adopted that paper
and I'll just point out for you because
you may not have been able to read it
but that paper is extremely well
researched it's tried and tested it's
been adopted by other councils and by
central government it was it was brought
into place in 2016 when Terror Liverpool
was Minister it has been active since
then it's a set of comprehensive
principles it deals with all the bases
of appropriate consultation with the
local ewe style quality of languages
placement of languages Etc if the
proposal today had been to adopt that
paper would you have been comfortable
with that as a way of moving forward on
a bilingual Journey
in this area
it would have to be a personal opinion
but I would probably say yes because
it's been designed and um
by knowledgeable experts in the field
through it obsolete a quite a
considerable amount of consultation
I would imagine
um that would have been the process so
having not read the paper fully or um
that would probably be my only comment
thank you that's something that's well
prepared well engaged
would be something obviously
um
that the members will have to agree with
but um we would probably personally I
can only say from a personal objects but
that sounds like it's a paper that could
be referred to to adopt
show that there was International
research done including basing parts of
the paper on the experiences in Wales
and I think you'll all be aware of the
revitalization of the Welsh language and
also the experience and with Scottish
and Irish
language revitalization
does that make you and others more
comfortable that that would be an
appropriate paper that's used
appropriate examples of how
revitalization of language could move
forward
yeah absolutely I would um you know when
we talk about
we uh we've come from um Maori from
Pacific routes but we also some of us
come from
um British roots or um United Kingdom
roots through our Scottish backgrounds
and all that so
um and you can see that those routes are
deeply tied to the Celtic ways of life
and the Celtic language and I and they
and the Welsh and the Irish languages
are all dual signage over there so I'm
not understanding why there would be a
problem
for us to have Maori across um because
there is there is a real unbalance there
is not too many signs out there in our
community that are um that have Maori on
where they should so it's saying that
there's an imbalance or we've seen too
much money that this is definitely not
the case there is to to grow our Maori
language El real
and to for it to be true partnership
there needs to be so much more just like
you say in Ireland just like you say in
Wales where it's that's part of the law
I don't know why it's not the law here
and it appears to be going that way but
I'm not sure why people would be opposed
to it because um you know that you know
there's a director an actual Direction
around
a real uh some revitalization because a
lot of people and back that have that
that more expertise around that ill than
I do but to grow our real
it's part of who we are it's part of
this country
yeah Tom
Dean one of the things that you said
that particularly interested me was when
you talked about the gifting process and
yeah and I'm paraphrasing this is not
your exact words but you sort of said
well as a two-way there's a consultation
involved you would not gift something
that was inappropriate and and I think
you know one one of the issues that I
personally have with metaphorical names
is that metaphors don't often work well
in two languages now when I look at to
anur it does work very well actually in
both languages when I look at tehanaki I
don't think it does so I was entering my
understanding was maybe I was completely
wrong my understanding was that that
name once gifted you know like a tablet
a stone from Heaven remains it you know
that there was no consultation I mean it
seems to me to be different I feel about
it differently if it's a consultation
where you know you might say look here's
here is a terio name which we think is
appropriate and then the other hand you
may say well actually in English you
know means ill means slippery and
devious and cunning and it's not really
actually a I mean I think that kind of
process would make me feel a lot more
comfortable about you know the gifting
and metaphorical names
well there's two ways there's the Maori
explanation of words there's a mighty
explanation of words and you've just
gotta you're probably gonna have to
accept that that that's the way that
Maori describe that particular word and
The Meta
um you know the metamorphic
um understanding of death that's the way
we do words that's the way we um might
name something and then there's English
I'm I'm pretty sure that sometimes they
don't they won't come together there's
no need for them to come together they
can totally
and um the reason it skipped it and then
the reasons behind the word will be
explained you know and you will
um I mean there's someone might say and
he also slippery
um base but it provides sustenance of
white Assassins but that's not the
reason the hinaki was was
um gifted and obviously it was a process
that went through I understand there was
a process this is about well-being this
is about the talks about this place as a
whole about a place of coming together
very much um why I understand that
that name
as as a as a name so a sing party like
it's about coming together resources
um a place like this so I think part of
that question maybe Dean I'm sorry
cutting across you but
um I did hear you talk about you know
the need for dialogue before her name
was actually gifted and that would make
me feel an awful lot more comfortable
because sometimes it can there can be a
misunderstanding in the names because it
means something in a metaphorical sense
completely different in English than it
might do in Maori in it and if there was
consultation about it
you know in advance to that gifting I
would personally feel a lot more
comfortable with metaphorical names
yeah uh Grant yeah and one would imagine
I understood that there was so because
we're through the that particular name
yeah that thinks
um yeah Dean um firstly thank you for
going through and taking us through the
paper because it's been very insightful
the key thing I want to take out of it
is that
probably two things you know the need
for consultation and the need for
partnership
but I just you know when you just said
their before in response to Tom's
question
around the different meaning within the
language different languages
and you and you know
the English version may just have to be
accepted so even though we may not be
comfortable with it because it means
slippery or something else we have to
accept it so I just wanted to
check that you know when we talk about
partnership it would be an agreed
partnership it's not acceptable to one
side then we have to go back to the
table and get acceptance or is there a
partnership
but it's got It's going to be dominated
by one party
so I just want to get some clarity on
your thinking around that saying that
I put a hearing and said there's a need
for partnership this should be already
an existing partnership with the Treaty
of waitangi if you know what I mean yeah
yeah
um and to say that though we need a
partnership it should just be in
everything that we do and so there isn't
a need because it should be what we're
doing that's what the treaty is all
about yeah so I don't just definitely
understand that there's and that there's
the English version on translations
words and says Maori just got to accept
that there are two there are two and the
reasons of that the gifting of names and
the Maori reason for gifting the names
and inherent it's not gifted lightly
there's going to be something beautiful
within that name
um so that's about all I can say Grant
is is that
um is it partnership should exist and we
should accept it but except these is
there an opportunity through that
conversation in your mind or your the
way you see the process where if it's
not accepted
then there's an opportunity to go back
to the table or do we does it just have
to be accepted
I would have thought that the the the
the early part of the early consultation
would would be working there are names
appropriate or not and I understood that
that did happen yes and some of the
names because um you wouldn't want to
you got him yeah and force a name on
somebody yeah it generally through most
of the names that I understand that
they're they have been talked about
right and I wouldn't understand why
Partners wouldn't engage in in that
process well it's logical but sometimes
logic doesn't Prevail all of it
very
yeah I've I've had a problem for a long
time with uh
Rayo being on top of
the English word on buildings and
sometimes it's not even on the English
version isn't on buildings
what's the question we were
we were all we're all told
taught English in school as we were
um and I have a bit of a problem
in fact we have a lot of problem with
it
uh excuse me excuse me can you just
leave me Heavies heavy side so that
that's that's why I've got a problem
with the two Raya Rayo name being at the
top because we we get tourists coming
into New Zealand
uh and excuse me I'm talking
um
we have tourists coming into New Zealand
and they look at a Maori building like
the one next door
or a museum and they have to ask someone
what is that building
that's crazy as far as I'm concerned yep
maybe it was a reflection on it our
education system back in the day that we
should have we shouldn't have our
parents shouldn't have been ostracized
or strapped like my father was some for
speaking the language at school so
there's those things that the real
should have come through the system
right from day dot but um there are
stuff in our past that that we shouldn't
be proud of when it comes to the
um and how the deal was uh to deal was
wanting to be subdued uh in the past so
because I understand uh your point Barry
but
um so I just when we were growing up
um the same thing we were taught English
first and but that's no reason
um that
um it shouldn't have been like that it
shouldn't have been like that we should
have I haven't got a problem
now now as um there's our language
Learners our language teachers are
coming through coming back reinforcing
our language so I go to overseas and um
it's not an expectation but I always see
go to Hawaii the Hawaiian language is
everywhere and that's part of my visitor
experience going on a holiday over to
Hawaii that all the names over there are
in Hawaiian and I look at them and I
think I need to work that name out
because it's a beautiful name I just
know it's got a beautiful meaning I need
to work that out so that's that's part
of my visitor experience to a country to
a country is trying to understand
people's language and their culture
language is a big part of it language is
a culture language is our culture and
altered all so it's um
um
yeah that's all I can say it's not just
on that night a very
good just on the uh on the video and all
that sort of thing I went to a cancer
school down Bluff and there's no Maori
spoke there because they weren't allowed
to speak it yeah but they're very happy
to get us I'm just saying a wireta
and I just think of Maori song so hey
what the hell yeah
I've got nothing more no no we're not
going to have any more debate because
we're actually we're just posing
statements that uh Dean and Sarah on
that's not what it's about you need to
ask questions so um I'm gonna have to
the end of this now for those who are
not familiar with how we work um oh
sorry Chris did you want to say
something
not really a question but I did want
um being mindful that we do have a
debate session to come yes I
it may be difficult what some people
think
you have to be mindful that we're on a
different pathway or you know on the
same pathway but a different place
good
um so the process from here on in for
those that are in the in the gallery and
Tony already knows this
um we're going to work our way through
the notes emotion which is tab 12 for
those Council around here because I
think it's appropriate that we don't
leave it till halfway through the
meeting to continue to do this
so um just for those who have not been
through a notice or motion process
before and for those in the gallery this
is this is the way it works
um we have a notice of motion put
forward
um the Mover and the signal gets some
chance to speak to the motion
um and then following on from that we'll
consider the paper that's been put up by
my learning colleague behind me or sorry
it looks like Andrew's going to do that
at one stage but that will that will
come after the Mover and second to have
had their opportunity to speak to the
motion if they want to
then we'll have a general debate
following on from that as part of that
General debate the two ewe delegates
will have the right to speak first
the Mover then has a right of reply and
then
um we will put the motion and democracy
will come into play
so as the person that's put the motion
up um I'll move the the motion be put up
thank you Tom so the process now is I'll
speak briefly to a paper and I won't go
through the paper that was attached to
the motion unless there's somebody in
the gallery that wants me sorry
yes
before you start Pro before you move the
process any further I want to invite you
as the Mover
to to alter your notice of motion so
that the words in accordance with the
attached paper are replaced with in
accordance with the Maori English
bilingual bilingual guide as appears at
12.2 of our agenda
I'm inviting you as the Mover yes well
let me respond to that before I make a
decision on that because that was put to
Dean earlier on about whether he would
accept it and and always loath not to
interject at that stage because I think
there were some traps in epidem to say
which you did say in good faith that he
would accept that document that came out
from the ministry of Maori development
because it has some traps in here so it
it is
a set of guidelines for the government
and the government only so it's not for
non-government agencies
and it has some conditions in there that
I don't think would favor
um
the voices that we've heard today so I'm
I'm opposed to adopting that
um Mary Engel
Mary English bilingual guide from the
government
excuse me Mia just a clarification on
what councilor Soper was asking from
what I understand in your notice emotion
the statement in accordance with the
attached paper is actually your written
words is the tax paper sure okay so
that's right I just want to make sure
that that's what been referred to sure
so I'm I'm sorry if that is your
decision your worship I think that is
unfortunate because that comprehensive
paper
would have made a very worthwhile
contribution to this debate today and I
am very sorry indeed that we are in the
situation where we are now going to
debate
the notice of motion of you as you have
put it Forward yep and I hear what
you're saying and that that paper that's
been put forward by staff which
discusses that document which I've got a
copy of here
we'll be discussed as part of the open
debate and it will inform counselors
what position they want to take at the
end now the bottom line is if you don't
like my paper you vote it down
and that leaves it open for you to have
an alternative
but I wish to have the uh the initial
um no summation as it stands
so um as a mover I just briefly want to
find out from the gallery where they are
familiar with the paper that's attached
to the nose animation
if there's anybody not familiar
Tony it's a yes or no
they're not familiar okay I'll read it
out because it's only a relatively brief
document
and then I'll speak to to that
um so it relates to the naming and
renaming of Civic buildings it's not
related to a signposts around on the
roads running like that's purely to the
Civic buildings background there's been
consumed within our committee that we
have no coordinate approach to this
issue Council needs to have a clear
process on these issues with neither
English or tyria being dominant but
dominated by the other community
concerns are reflected by and there are
five bullet points which Dean referred
to some buildings have an unequal focus
on tourier example iwakatuya that some
naming or renaming has the initial name
interio which creates confusion and an
example of that is he takanaki Civic
building so people don't know what that
is
that some Terio names are not related to
the nature of the building or what
services provided to the community
example TI anaki is ill pot in English
and that creates confusion
that the use of tyrio requires a harpu
or runaka input
and approval example that the U Sonic
that the use of tilio requires a harpu
or lunaka input and approval an example
is that we we struggle to get tane or
wahine into English around some of our
facilities onto things like Council
toilets and once a room like a gift has
of a name has been done it has to be
accepted the following process is a way
of all parties including staff being
clear on how Council wishes to approach
this issue to avoid ongoing unease in
the community the recommended process is
as follows the council has the right to
take a bilingual approach to the naming
and more and and also the renaming of
buildings to promote the use of tilio
that renaming under this bilingual
approach should be on a case-by-case
basis taking into account the historical
heritage
that historical Heritage to this city is
a culmination of European slash Scottish
and manafinoa this leads to not taking a
bilingual approach on such Heritage
venues as the Scottish Hall the ICC
debating chamber the Civic Theater and
the eve pool Civic Library
all new premises should have a bilingual
approach examples and new Museum
and propose new art gallery that t Rio
names that are not unique to the
specific venues should be promoted
oh should not should be promoted without
Rooney input example if we wish to have
toilets in the in the Queen's Park
to include wahine and tane that we
should have an ability to do that
that count the council does not approve
metaphorical names interio that means
names that denote something that is not
relevant to the building or service
provided
EG tihanaki on the Civic building
bilingual name displays that where
bilingual naming is used the English
version should be displayed first by
Theory and followed by Terrier giving
the very small number of tyrio speakers
that are available
I'll speak to that in a minute
um now the signage of each display is
equal IE one is not larger than the
other that the font maybe
um May afford some differentiation if
that is wanted and the same for color
for argument's sake if we had the ICC
Civic building hyphenated tahanaki the
tehanaki could be in a different font if
that was wanted
and also in a different color to donate
that it was stereo but the naming
display of criteria was also reflected
On promotional letterheads Community
engagement and online
so that's the backdrop to the motion
and the reason for that is as Dean quite
rightly said we have too many buildings
that have just single names on it most
of them English
and it would be my wish that we have
wherever possible a bilingual approach
it seems to me that there are examples
of where English is used and it's
maintained for everyone a day our
evolving Community is towards a
bilingual approach and the documents
that we're about to discuss from the uh
from te puny Corgi suggests just that
that we we need to promote too you know
um and so it was my view that by having
the standard policy we'd have an ability
to rename wherever we could
um buildings with a joint name as
opposed to just having the European
nameless traditionally been there
and also going forward that where we
have new buildings that we would also
have a buying bilingual approach as well
so that was my driving force for doing
that
and that's all I have to say on the
matter Tom has a signal do you wish to
add or do you wish to wait please yes
um look when I read this and I guess it
depends what I usually read it through
um I mean I saw the fundamental purpose
of this paper being to extend the
visibility of studio in the city to get
at an extent and has ever been seen in
invercargill before
by having nearly all city-owned
buildings given bilingual names
now I think we should all support that
initiative
and and frankly I think we should
recognize your role as Mia for bringing
this to this table for the first time in
the city's history
but the paper also proposes a protocol
for how that policy should be
implemented
and that is actually the far more
contentious part
but Samira I've lived in three other
countries which use bilingual signage
Canada Wales and Scotland LED in each of
these for a number of years
and in all of those countries it was
introduced with the very best motive of
bringing different language communities
together
but actually if anything resulted in
increased Division and acrimony between
those cultures at least initially
the most divisive issue always is which
language appears first
a special which is on top
and which is Lord on the scene
just those English words I've used talk
and lore
illustrate the issue because it is
perceived often subconsciously as a
symbol of cultural dominance a cultural
subservience by members of both
communities
whether it's French English Welsh
English or Gaelic English
The Ordering of words becomes a deeply
emotional issue for both language
communities as it will I'm afraid in
aotearoa New Zealand does not mean we
should not confront it we should
foreign
in my view we can avoid that issue
completely
we are not talking about signage here we
are talking about the naming of
buildings and the names which appear in
buildings
buildings are big things they've got
four sides
it would be very very easy in fact I
would say there is no reason why tyrio
and English names can it be put
at exactly the same height with neither
men predominating in every single case
that would be a much better
demonstration of partnership
than having one above the other which is
always unacceptable to either group
depending on who ends up at the bottom
therefore an appropriate time I do wish
to move to propose a change to the paper
specifically that in the section
bilingual name display
the first dot point is deleted and
replaced completely by the wording that
bilingual name signs on buildings should
always be located at the same height and
with neither predominant on all
buildings
foreign
can I point out that our own standing
orders mean that now that the particular
notice of motion has been moved and
seconded it it cannot be amended
I'll take some advice from Michael about
that
that um apologies Mr Mayor that is
correct
um it's been moved and seconded it needs
to be voted on now thank you after the
debate obviously but yes
so in the steaming orders that I'm
reading on page 53
after the motion is second and seconded
it says the notice of intention to move
an additional alternative motion needs
to be foreshadowed
so that's what he's done
yeah
inflamation move through
and then if if the my colleagues don't
want that paragraph in
then how do we how do we mean that out
as as Thomas said
[Music]
bear with me as a legal opinion on this
okay so the legal opinion I'm getting
from Michael
is correct that after we've had the
debate time is able to move that
Amendment and we can then vote on it
Evelyn
may I ask point of clarification
when you spoke earlier you indicated
that
panya and I would be given
this coach and I as monofino we've given
an opportunity to speak but it sounded
to me like it was after the debate had
been held now I want that clarification
I I'm just clarifying it for you we were
going to have a discussion now with
Michael's input on the paper that staff
have presented to this motion then we're
gonna have a general debate and the
first two speakers will be the two minor
final reps
okay
then we'll have a general debate with
the council is involvement
uh
pioneer more
I just sent the people who came to
support this because it's so important
for us and it's a very painful
conversation for us to be having sure
appreciate that
Andrew can we go back to
sorry yeah sorry I thought you finished
foreign
so there's been a lot said today about
different names and what they might mean
and what this might mean for us going
forward as a person who has been
intrinsically involved no sorry sorry
Reuben I I need to stop you there this
is not the place for this this part of
the debate I need to allow the staff to
give us the input first then you get the
chance to speak to that we need to be
informed by what the staff are telling
us before we get into the general debate
Andrew but only Michael's paper I just
thought I'd stand here in case there's
any questions oh someone to throw to me
yeah uh thank you thank you um antenna
Couture uh this paper uh very briefly
and as you can see from the paper being
a very brief paper simply introduces the
guidance form to Pune cookery that in
the event that staff were developing the
policy this is where we would turn uh to
to seek guidance and is therefore useful
to inform uh the council laws in their
debate on what staff would use as a
starting point for uh any policy that we
would develop to bring before you
and they
paper is developed primarily for central
government but it is also designed to
apply for all government agencies which
includes local government and is also
designed as a best practice guide for
businesses who wish to go down the
bilingual approach
with that and as Andrew wants to add
anything else and I don't think there's
much else I can add
I didn't actually intend to say anything
but I it was interesting listening to
the submissions in the public art and
and some are questioning and I think
and this is the law in me being
analytical about this there are more
than one part to this question and what
is clear and I think the mayor touched
on these two Associates then what is
clear in that paper from the government
and that you'll see coming through in
Road signage and where the Dual language
and what Tom referred to it deals with
that
how everyone describe it the the
difficult question I'm ordering
and it is clear that the government
central government through its powers
and processes have dealt with that
question and that is one part of the
question that you're considering today
and and I think the guidance on that and
the consistency around the country is
very clear
the second part is this question of
literal translations and there are
certain places in certain times where
literal translation is the way that it
occurs
um we all know those as Kuru school and
you can see that coming through in their
own signs you can see that dealt with
there is then the third question which
was again been touched on here where
there may be a name that a literal
translation does not work or is not
appropriate
and I think it's important when
considering and we would consider if you
ask for us for a policy on this those
three different questions almost
separately because they are very
different questions and the partnership
approach the way you would approach that
would be very different depending on
what the question was
and so I think it's it's just worth
bearing that in mind because you can
bundle all those things into one issue
when they're all very different
um Michael has some questions for you
the document you quoted which was some
tipuni cookery
um a forward from the minister of Mary
development uh The Honorable level
um when I read through this document I I
want just to note a few things actually
excuse me could you put some microphone
closer to your mouth sure thank you
um so when I read through this document
which is one of three documents I might
add there was one back in 2003 the Maori
language strategy and the subsequent
auditor General's uh review of the
public sector
um went to Parliament in 2009 which
didn't show a very good
um uptake of uh signage which I think
Dean has alluded to
um but when I read this document it's
clear to me that this talks about the
government sector not the the local
government sector so that's the first
thing but all the way through it talks
about
the visibility of Tyrion
and in my paper I'm quite clear that I
want more than we've got at the moment
I want to wherever possible have
bilingual nowhere in this document does
it refer to
um Terio and only tuio so I just want to
get that confirmation out of it
yeah sorry um thank you Mr Mia so that
while the paper is primarily focused uh
sorry well the report from Japan is
primarily focused at the government
sector the paper does and the supporting
document does say it is also for local
government agencies specifically and n68
yeah yeah in the Strategic uh
called the Strategic
objective
is the overall objective is developing
bilingual signage guidelines
um to increase the visibility of today
Maori in public spaces within the
government Central and local extending
to business sectors
um
so that is there I'm not otherwise going
to uh dispute uh or
make comment on you'll notice emotion
and misdemeer that is uh your matter as
I said the staff paper was simply for
additional information for the
councilors in yourself when you're
making this decision on your noticeable
motion
so I will now put to you a couple of
um
quotes from The Honorable in that
document because I think it's important
that we understand when we come back to
the issue of do we adopt this document
straightforward or not
um so
um
uh the unworth level says there needs to
be more prominent and visibility in
public information and services which
includes building signage
um
and it also addresses what is a
bilingual sign and I and I quote this
policy does not require such information
or publicity material to be produced
bilingually it helps to have an approach
that will help make decisions
and it goes on further to say good
business practice is taking language
equality will return you positive
results to your organization which I
support
and their very end says
interestingly that promotes both
languages equally but not a blend of
both
so they were the major thrust was the
issue of visibility
and the issue of ensuring that um we
didn't have one at the expense of the
other in my paper I was already aware of
these documents and I took those things
into account
so I just want you to
to tell me whether I've got that wrong
because this document will become
important there's Leslie has thrown up
um if we want to adopt something else as
opposed to the paper that I've put up
uh thank you Mia Clark now absolutely
that is the comments from uh minister
flevel in his uh introductory uh
comments yeah and I don't dispute that
that is the intention of the paper again
I go back to a staff with preparing a
policy this is where we would start from
because it is guidance from central
government on how to approach with this
it's not to say that we have to adopt
the pay the to Pune cookery report as
whole and adulterated but that's where
we would start
as a staff starting point for drafting
yep
and just as a final comment and just
please help me out I've got this wrong
um the rules applying to bilingual
language as an internationally
recognized standard shows that the first
language
um
and how important it is when you have a
second language to make sure that you
don't
um
over emphasize one language that
um one language is if it's longer than
the other
um should as Tom says alongside
and you don't have font that's larger
and one and smaller than the other
because that minimizes
um
and that only only if that's not
practical in your eyes
of of an easily reading person would you
then have Maori uh text Dominic
and I think that was advice given to
council earlier on in the piece
indeed in that as the commentary within
the document and it also um assigned
alliance with uh guidance from the
United Nations sure Andrew sure
it's on our role to enter into this
debate but it is a debate around
language and again the lawyer and we
can't help but uh
pick up and it was touched on bottom the
use of the word dominate
um and and that
is implying uh in suggesting that the
guidance promotes the through your
question that these guidance promotes a
Domination by an ordering preference and
I would
caution against making that conclusion
let me put it that way
okay yep questions for Michael Oher
Andrew Tom
um
Michael or Andrew as I read this and I
did reduce people very carefully and
it's almost exactly it assumes the Welsh
language paper I think it's been picked
it's not really a Scottish or Irishman
that's a Welshman
but the
um I mean I I had my mind as I was
reading that we were not talking about
in order sports or pamphlets but we were
talking about buildings
and the the advice in the paper
um is that wherever possible the two
languages should be given equal
status which I took to be meaning Say by
say now I think we could get in a rabbit
hole when we start to visualize
pamphlets and signs and so forth because
that's actually not what we're talking
about we're talking about the naming of
buildings and how that name should
appear on the buildings
which can always be side by side and
which in no way conflicts me anything
that depending co-create advising but
would that not be the case turn on any
equation it really goes to the and
that's why I said these these three
separate and distinct questions here
what you're really talking about and and
uh
leading silent is the order and and so
so answer your question this paper deals
clearly with the ordering on a building
in terms of which ones on the left which
one's on the right it doesn't deal with
anything else other than to say they
should both be the same size fine
otherwise
but but you're leaving silent the bit
that it does deal with does it deal with
whether that's a exact translation or a
gifted name or no but it but it deals
with the ordering question
the guidance deals so my question I mean
my question was that isn't it the case
the Pinnacle crew paper recommends it
wherever possible they should be given
equal
prominence it's only where there is not
enough room
that you find that they do recommend
that cereal appears above the other one
seems in Wheels it's not a really above
it's left or right and then I just I'm
not talking about left array I'm talking
about one above the teller I don't think
left at eight matters you're right it's
only if there's not room for left to
right from both the run so the point I'm
making is that we're going down a rabbit
hole by debating something we don't need
to debate we're talking here about the
names and buildings and it can the name
and buildings can easily be put side by
side without even having a debate around
your book whether we put one above each
other which one should should Dominate
and I don't think that's in any way
conflicts with tapone's paper yeah Tom
might I just clarify though but one
issue about naming a building is that on
the correspondence that we put out as a
council we then refer to that building
so you have to remodel it when you put
out rate bills or when you put out
consultation papers where people might
be asked to direct to come to the
building you want them to know where
that building is
so hence my English first and to Rio
second which is in my paper Andrew said
uh not left to right but my paper
clearly does say left or right and I'm
open to the removing the top to bottom
any other questions for either staff
member Leslie oh sorry pania no I'll pan
here first
so um
spoke about earlier around the paper
what I actually want to say that it is
in in conflict with their paper from tpk
if you read it in more depth so what
obviously you want to sort of highlight
is that it doesn't remove metaphors
which your paper does and our language
is built on metaphors the other thing I
want to sort of note as well is that
there is a bilingual design
and so when within that paper there's a
design tips and I just want to briefly
read them quickly
had the font for the Maori takes at
least as large as the font for the
English even if one text runs longer
use an equal typeface for Maori in
English use the same font style for
Maori in English apply color coding to
text and language separating background
panels because it's in the north signs
with the same color in positioning of
each language
also Place Maori first either stacked or
side by side if both Maori and English
cannot be easily read because the
signage is visibly busy consider having
the Maori only so there is
this is totally opposite to some of what
you have actually within your paper
correct
so that wasn't a question for one of the
two staff members but I'll take that on
board what you said and I will respond
to it
because one of one of the primary
focuses of a building is not necessary
to promote tourio
primary responsible building is to
direct people
to the building and what the building
the building provides so um in my in my
view
um is that that should be the primary
indicator where people are going to
if you if you have a metaphorical
term which
Tom said he didn't agree with
um but you've said you do agree with
them so did Dean as well if you have
that then you confuse the uh the nature
of the building if you have that as the
primary left to right configuration
but it's okay I mean you probably need
to come back down when we have the
debate shortly if
enable
questions for the staff thank you
I think also quoting from some of what
the minister said in the Preamble to
this paper because I think that's
important and then ask my question of
Andrew and Michael sure
so I'll quote where the minister said
you are in a position of influence to
make a difference for turiamari
to make it visible to make it normal
the guide was informed by the experience
of experiences of countries where
bilingual signage is also part of the
language revitalization to encourage
good practice
through the new Maori language act and
I'll remind everybody that in 2016 the
original Murray language Act was updated
to include some new Clauses about the
encouragement that could be given for
the revitalization of Tori Omari
through the new Murray language Act and
the development of the Mahi karuna the
government has committed to enhancing
the support for Taria Murray
revitalization by all agencies as a
normal part of the way we do business
one way in which we will achieve this is
to ensure tariyomari is more visible to
the communities we work in
yes to Rio Mari is the official language
of New Zealand but it is also more than
that because it belongs to no other
country but ours a beautiful language
your language our language
further into that document
which I'll remind you from what I've
read is also very much about the
encouragement of the revitalization of
the Maori language and the way that the
Welsh language was revitalized
there is a very clear statement that
says
things about the placement
on the equal signs that are being talked
about including the signs on buildings
and it makes it very clear that the
placing of the first language that is
the language you are trying to
revitalize
should be placed first that is in a
stacked sequence
Murray at the top English below
and I left to right sequence Mari on the
left English on the right
the document then talks about other ways
in which you can differentiate the two
languages so that people's eyes are LED
if they wish to one or other of the
languages as the primary
but in the revitalization of language it
is quite clear and this is my question
to Michael and to Andrew
in my reading of the document is quite
clear that the placement question the
order is supremely important in the
revitalization of the language and that
is what we are talking about today we
are not just talking about the bilingual
naming of our buildings we are talking
about the global issue of the
revitalization of a language a tayonga
that we hold dear
foreign
I believe that the document is a
multifaceted document with a number of
aims including as its Forefront purpose
as the revitalization of Maori in
government business but it covers a
number of different aspects as has been
highlighted already today
Andrew did you have any comments same
kind it's clearly that was part of the
thinking behind the Russian and as the
mayor alluded to and Tom alluded to it's
consistent with the approach taken
around the world for those purposes
um to ensure that the language is uh
looking and in summary it makes the
point that uh picking up councilor
Stewart's point if you only understand
English you're all I will quickly jump
to the English and you'll see that and
so it's to Pro putting it on the left
promotes the understanding and the the
desire to understand the other language
and that's why it's done that way it's
that's the Strategic purpose thank you
yeah well
um so to this to
um
Mr Cameron Mr Morris
um I just want to draw your attention to
the Mahi Corona which is the 2019-2023
language revitalization strategy which
supports the 2016 and were you aware of
that and will that be used in designing
any future policies should we be given
the opportunity
I'll probably touch on that one because
of the nature of the notice of motion
this is not a whilst you can't help but
touch on the revitalization question
the notice of motion he's not asking
Council to adopt a strategy for
revitalization so this document stands
alone and separate from those strategies
as a guide for government informed by
the strategy including local Council
which is informed by the strategy but is
not
doesn't require Council to adopt a
strategy to promote
Maori to adopt this approach which is
consistent with the rest of the country
if if you are asking Council War of the
most emotion dealt with a strategy for
Council to promote that's a different
question and that's why but yes we are
aware of the more the updated strategy
so the fact that the strategy talks
about visibility
um the sound the use that all those
things as being the positive that would
add to the richness of our city and
therefore
and should we the notice Council be
being
Avid adopters because it's something
that would actually
um add to
how people see us
promote us if you like as as an
inclusive and welcoming place it's a
subtly different question which which is
not for me to answer to be honest to be
honest fair enough thank you Trish
um thank you
first of all I'd like to congratulate
the mayor for Having the courage to
bring this to this table we want to make
sure that we do adopt a bilingual
approach it's really important
can I ask you Michael or Andrew whoever
it is if we
accept this motion does that mean that
the recommended processes we accept
those as well or can there be discussion
further on that can we accept the motion
and then come back to the detail which
is what we're talking about now
so it's so the notice of motion as it is
sets out what is proposed by the mayor
to happen uh as part of that there can
be policy work done in behind it which
is the detail I
think you're alluding to Yes
um
but the notice of motion would set a
resolution and set where council's
direction is going
yeah just I think the the question was
asked by councilor pottinger before the
paper would adopt effectively that
process behind it we might be able to
tweak within that process but but to the
extent that that process says one thing
we wouldn't go against that so to the
extent that that process for instance
and I'm not trying to be inflammatory
here but but calls out no metaphorical
names we would not be able to adopt a
metaphorical name under under a process
consistent with that resolution
so how could we then add what councilor
Campbell has suggested that we change
that first point
that's that is through the amendment
process to the motion uh which can can
occur uh during after sorry the debate
uh when certain motion is really for
um after after that debate once the
motion is ready
um councilor Campbell can then propose
his motion he's already foreshadowed
that he is going to do that
thank you
other questions for the staff
there being none
so I get to speak again to the
motion before we start opening up for
the debate for to be led to the um to
Mana offender it
but it's a just probably a statement for
Tom
um who's the signal for this
would you be open to as was suggested by
Teresa the motion being mindful that the
motion
um
requires bilingual
names on all buildings where possible
um
and that the attached paper could be
developed at a later stage to give some
um
some meaning to some of the debate that
we've had today is that something you'd
be open to yes sure sure
okay
so I'm sorry but could you clarify what
you mean by this statement well I think
and her Trish through Outlet uh threw up
with the idea that we could approach as
a council a bilingual approach to any
naming or renaming of Civic buildings
and that the naming shall be expressed
in a dual manner how we actually do that
which is the issue of is it top to
bottom is it left to right which take
prominence over the other given that
that's it seems to be an area of concern
could be developed on a paper later on
with staff input and and monofinware
input if that was required that would
give a little bit more meat to that
motion
so you're therefore
the notice of motion would be altered to
put a full stop after dual manner
correct well that's that's what I was
asking Tom whether he was open to that
we around the table can have some
discussion about that well Tom's
foreshadowed a different Amendment yep
so time are you foreshadowing that you
would put up that Amendment
we're in due process and you're losing
me a little bit but
um look I think with the mirrors
proposing is I mean it's almost
not because it's taken a win and doing
some more work on it
um
my my proposal was to change a single
dot point it may be that if it was taken
away
and brought back it might be that
there's several dot points that may be
rewarded so and and that there may be
more Comfort around the table around
that
so um I'm going to be gated by
processness because it's not clearing me
just where we are I mean I'm comfortable
putting my motion
um which would remove that above and
below and replace it with uh you know
side by side
however
um the mayor's motion to take it away
and I think you don't know if you use
the word rework but that's how I would
interpret it
um might give a better outcome
so in Balance I think it would support
where the mirror said
if I'm the right place in the
time for a general debate
Evelyn or pioneer
uh
you have laid the challenge before us so
the first thing leaving aside what any
changes may be made by yourself or the
secondary of the motion
I think it's only fair that we should
say
the things that we have been thinking
about since this notice of motion came
to our attention
the first thing is
the prominence of English is a de facto
prominence it's not actually a dejured
language of New Zealand it is a de facto
language of New Zealand the two Dura
languages of New Zealand arterial which
happened in 1987 in New Zealand sign
which happened in 2006. I think in all
of this
that point has been lost English became
the dominant language by the importation
oh in the 19th century of hundreds of
thousands of people who only spoke
or mostly only spoke one language and
that was English
it was further
given dominance by a oppressive and
suppressive
language strategy
undertaken by
agents of the crown
leaving that aside there's some things
in here in what it was has been said
that are effectually incorrect Bruno
have never asked to affirm or veto
common practice words such as Tanya and
wahine
never
I have been asked
as part of signage what is current
practice common practice is
universal sign
because everybody no matter what
language looks at somebody that is
wearing trousers and interprets that as
male and somebody that is wearing a
skirt as being female or leave aside
cultural differences from countries
where neither clothing is worn
um so put that away
arter Museum
is named in large letters all along the
building which means it can be read
either way
depending on what angle you approach the
building from depends on whether you see
at a museum first or hero Academia
however hey wakatoa has been the
branding
it has a meaning
it was the name that was gifted
we were asked to gift that name and we
did
in your document you talk about the
heritage of this place
as being European Scottish and manafinoa
now I spoke to one of our whanau
I'm sure she wouldn't mind if I said
what her name is
who is a direct descendant of John Kelly
in hanita Hawaii
and
her tupuna was around about 13 or 14
years old when they came to live in the
city or what became the city
the right to be here come because hinatu
Hawaii was too Hawaii's sister
she never let it be forgotten that there
were children living here of Maori
Heritage before there was ever
a non-money child born to John Kelly in
the system
stories that we have been giving you as
part of the cultural Narrative of the
city are all to do with these place
names the importance of the food sources
that were here at the time these people
came it's what
actually made it possible
for settlers to settle here the fact
that the history was rich in food
the fact that the river was rich in food
the fact that Toyota had plenty of trees
the autardo I had plenty of trees this
is what made living here possible
in 1856 without a supermarket a
refrigerator or electricity
place names that we have given you like
tahinaki
actually directly connect to a strategy
that you made in May 9 2022
which included the naming of the
buildings
uh the meeting rooms in this building
so you use names of Tonga species that
come out of this book
the NATO who Claims Settlement Act 1998.
those names
weka
Etc
talk about food resources that were here
foreign
ERS utilized to keep themselves alive
until another ship came
so ahinaki was really important
that is how you caught tuna
if you were careful where you put it you
might actually get a party or whatever
as well but
that was Irrelevant this is what you
were going for you were looking for
nourishment the name tahinaki was given
because this building is approximate
those places
thank you we did not find it out of
fresh air
it talks about the Gathering of
resources for the well-being of the
people
that is what this building does
it gathers resources for the well-being
of every citizen it brings us together
as people as we are today to help us
understand one another better
to come to a place where instead of
being in Conflict we find some mutual
meeting ground
and that's
part of the narrative that we have been
telling so as you walk along is straight
and you see the toner and you see the
howl and you see the huamanu and you see
the Pataki the Kana and the power and
the Wicker that's running away with the
boot lace it all tells the story
of what this place was like
before we changed it forever
it's not accidental that we're telling
those stories
when we placed
malafinua when we placed a beautiful
woman outside
one of the main entrances of ICL she's
facing towards
her companion piece who is in Dawn
Street
who is called mahikakai
because that is part of this
it is the ninth Tall Tree of the
nighttime settlement it talks about how
vital our food resources were to us way
back then and what we would like them to
still be right now
in this document the crowns
first
words apart from saying what the ACT is
interior Maori
he quoted to a Time
Toto oh God I can't even say
English becomes secondary and that's the
explanation as it is in the apology from
the crown to us this is because of the
law of Contra preferentum which is part
of the Treaty of waitangi which is why
the Maori version is the preferred
version It's international law I find it
really sad
that we're being asked to make our
language less than it can be that the
examples that we are going to show to
people are less than the full richness
because it makes some people
uncomfortable
the metaphors the oratory of our people
are in the names that we give
hewakatuya is about uniting and weaving
together and it was weaving at that time
weaving together art and Museum
because neither Place had a home
that was what data is about we've talked
about tahinaki to unawa which is the
other contentious name
a voyaging double held rocker it holds
two different peoples it helps do
different contents that holds art and
Museum or
um history and the present all those
dualities that we can create in that
building
exploring together
a future in a new place in a new space
to reduce all these things to I don't
understand it or I don't like it or I'm
uncomfortable with it is doing
the monofino of this place a disservice
as as being said we've been here for
more than 800 years if you look at where
our place names are
I think Tom must feel very at home in
the inner city with all the Scottish
River names
some of our people will feel a little
bit more comfortable as they go out and
they find Victoria Avenue and Tim's
Street and all those sorts of things how
far do you have to go as a Maori person
to find a street name that talks to you
you can go to Utah there's quite a few
there
or you could go to the far-flung suburbs
you could go to vically
one of the sole surviving traditional
names of this place that is here that is
lest you be like the person who keeps
going and blocking out the macrons on
otatra on the signs going out there
it could imagine what I ask you to
reconsider what you have put in this
paper it is divisive it divides this
table for a start never mind the wider
Community but more than that it speaks
to me of a great disrespect for the
beauty of the real that we're raising
our tamariki mokopane Within
what we want them to see what we want
them to hear what we want them to
experience you're also denying our
presence and I'm sorry that we're only
four percent of the population but we're
multi-billionaires and I think that that
is important to acknowledge as well
because we have done that by working
really hard
with the resources that come out of this
we have done it by being entrepreneurial
we have done it by our language
strategies
a thousand homes speaking to real
the crowns document talks about a
million homes in 2040.
compared to our percentage of the
population a thousand homes by 2025 is a
much higher aspiration
may we see this reflected in the city
where I was born where I grew up where I
was educated where I raised my child and
where I hope that my mokopuna will one
day be proud to stand and celebrate the
beautiful Legacy that we have left on
the face of the city and finally can I
remind
you it's where that the eve pool library
is the eve pool library to hyatta and
that was made long before I had any
influence at the table
can we celebrate these things can we
rejoice in these things and can we
please not do this ever ever again
you want to contribute
first of all I want to acknowledge our
whanau Arana here today thank you for
coming
and and for some s supporting
in regards to this this um I don't know
what to call it actually to be honest
I'm just a bit um disappointed I suppose
when I read the paper in the first place
um
I don't know how many times that we have
to say around this table that literally
in the first of the 19th century
you know Maori Maori
was the first language
and both normally and Maori good speaker
It's just sad that the second you know
when we talk about the second half of
the 20th century they're almost our
culture in our language was destroyed or
stripped from us is probably the nice
way and it said now that in this current
times we have been reclaiming our
culture in our language
but on the other hand I'm I'm you know I
agree totally with my colleague over
there around
um
around where we have been and with
everyone that has spoken in
the um public forum today
I suppose what I just want to add is I
hope that we can revisit and and reshape
your Mo you'll notice emotion on the
table because it does not meet
or feel right when we talk about
Community concerns in your paper what
about the concerns from Maori
you know there is no partnership
whatsoever
in this paper
even around the proposed recommendations
and process this is totally concerning
that we
that we're not really reflected or part
of that discussion
I know that we don't have a boat here
today and I realize that um
that we're here in really
hoping in some hoping that the councils
the councilors actually take our
concerns on board
in making the final decision and I do
have to also say I do support what you
said right from the beginning councilor
Soper that maybe that's Motion in
accordance with the tpk paper or the
crown strategy for Maori language
revitalization would be more appropriate
to alignment than the Miss paper
there
thank you Mia Clarke
um look I'll start with something light
before I dive into the meat
uh I saw a meme recently
somebody holding up a teddy bear and it
said you show me on the door where today
I hurt you
either it wasn't me that was it no no
um I think it's unfortunate that
the discussion we're having at the
moment comes at a time when things are
emotionally charged
and they're emotionally charged around
some of the co-governance discussions
that have been going on in the community
I'm not touching that with a 10-foot
barge pole because we need to focus on
this
and I think we're starting to head in
the right direction
I want to make sure that we're creating
a city that values the use of today on
Maori I'm not able to cut it off fluent
in today I have a basic understanding
uh
my youngest son gave me a couple of
books last year for my birthday Scotty
Morrison's books on how to learn to
speak at today
I said come on dad catch up
uh and I love them for that
because it's a great Challenge and you
know we went out to consult with the
Youth of our community a couple of
months ago which I think was a really
good thing to do and actually if you
think about where the youth are now
that's a space that they're already in
and it's it's up up to us to catch up it
is difficult and challenging and
confronting sometimes I come at the End
of the Age of the cultural repression
that was going on through education
system
uh and didn't know any better until you
know you go in your own Voyage of
self-discovery
but the young people are there already
and I've had some pretty clear feedback
from them over the last week
and over the last couple of days
but they are there my my son went to
work and
greeted a custom with counter got a
Kyoto back in katipei
his response
was he had to explain it to me because I
knew most of it was pretty I'm tired oh
okay fine
this is the space that kids are in
they're young people this is the
community that they want
if we talk about Partnerships I live in
a partnership
um where you know my wife and I have
discussions about things before I decide
to agree with her
because more often than not she's right
but Partnerships are an alongside thing
and you know that's that's the journey
on life that that she and I go through
very lucky
and I'm supporting an approach that
looks at bilingual equal signage
but I think what many people don't
understand is that today Mari is a
language of metaphor
um and that sometimes those things don't
translate and you know what that's no
different to many of the languages
through Europe
I can think of a German translation that
in German means something completely
different to what is being used
elsewhere
and it's not unique
so we want I think most of us to ensure
that the Revival of today Maori is is
reflected I think the document from
tikonikokity
is a really good starting place
but
as the as the motion stands I can't
support it because it talks down the the
metaphorical use of language
um and and that's at the heart of it
we don't necessarily need to understand
the metaphor it's being open to
understanding it it might come it it
might not that's fine
our place I've always mentioned to Papa
first I don't say I'm going to our place
while we're in Wellington or the
national museum but it's just
it's become bigger than it needs to be
and it really
upsets me you know we've all had
plenty of approaches over the last short
while and
you know our emotions are probably
heightened coming into today
yeah
but I'm interested in supporting
emotion that
gives equal status sees things side by
side values the use of today Amari
recognizes the partnership
and understands that there are
differences between
our languages
and in some cases our way of life and in
some cases our values but that's
the beauty of it that's what we've got
that nobody else has anywhere else in
the world so
I understand that
the motion may change
there will be amendments I will watch
very closely to see where they go but
that's where I'm sitting at the moment
I want to see bilingual building signage
in our city and if it means more work on
a paper to refine that that's that's a
that's a good thing but
I want to see us more than anything
value that relationship because there's
this bit of damage that needs to be
patched up
thank you
foreign
I'll also I'll also start in a slightly
roundabout way um
I want to say as the soul surviving
counselor who worked for two years to
create and fund hey wakatuya Art Plus
Museum
as an interim solution to the closure of
both the Southern Museum and art gallery
and the invercargill public art gallery
that we spent a great deal of time
weaving together two organizations who
had separate identities and had not
worked together before
hey wakatuya the boat that carries us
all
that was the perfect metaphor for what
we were creating and hey wakatoa we were
creating until 1225 as a reality a
chance for airtelonga to be seen
because we were we were having a venue
that was open for the display of both
Museum and art
we were delivering art and Museum
together we were saying yes you still
have access to your public collections
to the history and the stories into the
variety of art Endeavors hey wakatuya
the boat that carries us all
you look at the the
Art Plus Museum now and as has already
been pointed out depending on the
direction from which you approach you
see either hey wakattui or Art Plus
Museum first
choose what is best for you but
acknowledge that both those both those
terms have an important part in the
reality of what we created there as an
interim transition space for the
treasures of this place
and that's what we wanted to achieve
the boat that carries us all for me was
the perfect metaphor to describe what we
were creating there
moving to the actual notice of motion
and I have to talk to the noseless of
motion as it is currently moved
and it's a It's associated paper
I'm sad and that we have this notice of
motion and the associated paper here
today
I'd be ashamed if I didn't
speak against adopting it as it
currently stands
to me the notice of motion as it
currently stands with the attached paper
to be accepted as a whole
is taking us back 50 plus years in New
Zealand history
taking us back to
New Zealand where I grew up we're the
grandparents and sometimes the parents
of the people I went to school with had
Murray beaten out of them in their
classrooms
to a New Zealand that was unable to
accept that we had a covenant between
peoples called to tariti or waitangi
and remember it had not been that long a
time before that that legally
the treaty had been called a simple
nullity
we were quite late in the piece in 1975
coming to the point where we had a
treaty of waitangi act that gave to
teriti a legal place
an effirmament
taking us back to a place where
to Rio was not an official language it
now is it deserves a respect air
protection and air obligation as part of
the Revival of Tori Omari
and that is the wider context in which
we are looking at what is before us
today
the motion as it stands and the attached
paper to me is coming from a place of
fear of positive change
misunderstanding of New Zealand's unique
history and New Zealand's changing
demographic
thank you to every one of you who has
come today
and your children who as councilor
Ludlow has already pointed out are the
future who have already accepted the
place of the normalization of to Rio in
New Zealand
who are already there
we want to make sure that this council
is also there at the end of this
discussion
I want to point out that we have the
chance
to do a great deal
as a council to assist the
revitalization of Torio
to make a principled point about the
bilingual naming
of air buildings about bilingual signage
but
if we are going to adopt an attached
paper
that says incorrectly that some
buildings have an unequal focus on Torio
and uses the example of haywakatuia
that talks about
unease ongoing in their community
when all the unease I have heard
in the last few days to me is unease
about
the notice of motion actually being
passed in its current form with the
associated paper saying what it does
with a paper that suggests that
metaphorical names in Torio should never
be adopted
when we know that is the essence of Tori
Omari
and as of extreme importance to the
names we've been gifted
that implies in the additional paper
that
somehow runaka have tried to gift us
names we did not ask for
every name every Terio name we have been
gifted is because we asked
arunaka to gift us the name
and yes they all came to us with
consultation and yes last year we did
adopt some fairly
powerful and I thought
decisive
um
words about what we believed about the
importance of Tori Amari
and how it could play a part in this
councils going forward
yes I am
horrified at the idea that we would
adopt an additional paper that suggests
English version should be displayed
first given the very small number of
Torio speakers
message does that send and what is the
point of of having that message there
when we are trying not to divide but to
come together
and and then it
the additional paper goes down to the
the question of fonts and
differentiation perhaps by using
Electronics
well I'm sorry but the guidelines and
the cokery paper do have things to say
about the use of
italics for differentiation for instance
the use of unequal size of fonts
the use of color
the need for some standardization and
for some actual thought to go into what
is produced I'm sorry but I cannot
vote for
the notice of motion as it currently
stands
I did try to ask early in this
conversation that we
replace in accordance with the attached
paper to in accordance with the Maori
English bilingual signage guidelines as
already and at agenda today because I
think they are a very productive and
reasonable way to move forward
foreign
but I cannot accept
that we would adopt today without my
strong protest
a notice of motion and an Associated
paper
that divides rather than brings together
thank you
right
um I support the Bolling approach to
naming buildings as well there's a
couple of things I've noted Dean you
comment around the First Nations thing I
think that's something we really need to
take into account in terms of the
prioritation of the naming I think
that's a really important point you've
made there and I think we should give
that consideration
it's reinforced in the tapuna cookery
paper so the other piece I think I see
um is an opportunity for us to take this
moment and walk forward together
and I'd like to accept
um Cyril's invitation to come down and
you know have a Hui or an argument
um you know because I think I think it's
you know
I'd like to see that well we might use
the tapuna cookery paper as a guide I'd
like to see if there's any opportunity
for us to build in
unique references or protocols that
reflect airphone out in terms of America
so I think we need to take that
opportunity
um as well so look I think the approach
that we're getting towards around
you know we we need to accept that we
want to take a bilingual approach I can
support but I equally think we need to
redefine the process we will take to get
to the point we need to get to which
brings us together
and so that's the approach on supporting
whichever way that looks
thank you Trish
um I absolutely agree with you grant I
think we do we are moving forward we do
want a bilingual approach we will be
known as a council who try to make a
difference and we mean it for the best
reasons
um with the associated paper now it
doesn't seem to be
what we all want or what whether we need
to have further discussion so I in
essence would agree with it but not with
not as it currently stands I do believe
that we are moving the right way
foreign
this is not the sort of forum where I
feel the complicated issue around you
know detailed one thing is going to be
resolved
um and and therefore you know in my view
by Hoover means that it's done I I would
have been clean to leave this motion on
the table
and go and do some more work on it
um
I'll come back in a minute
others you want to spin
yeah
you agree with Tom
so Tom
being being that you and I are the
movers and Signal of this motion
I just want to run something past you to
see where we can get some common ground
if the paper the motion took out the
words after Jewel Manor which is sitting
up there so it takes away the attached
powder
and we insert a second part to it which
says that um
that this bilingual approach will be
supported by a paper that gets developed
in the future
so that allows people to have different
views to come into the into the play
with that suit
well I I think the the part of the paper
that everybody would be agreed upon
would be the first sentence wouldn't it
sure that we um the councilor Dr
bilingual approach to any naming and
renaming of Civic buildings
and of that naming shall be an
expression of German I don't know how
far I'd go before I put a full stop sure
but uh but I certainly I would be
surprised if it was anybody in this room
that would disagree with that for since
so I think that we ought to be able to
move and resolve that second part well
how then do you
um develop a protocol for that
um I guess
but I think it needs to be taken away so
I I think that the
um it may be that we simply resolve
number one
um and number two when it gets rewarded
the council develops a pip that Council
develops a paper to support the
bilingual
approach so that allows us to go to the
different parties that are here today
yeah so I would personally support
that motion as it now reads yeah
so I'm prepared to amend accordingly
unless I have some objection from around
the table no no objection
um
me a clock I'd wonder whether to two
just to put
hail that Council develops a paper to
support the bilingual approach taking
into account the 2016 to Puna kokori
paper and consultation with the for
roonaka i would support the same party
though but not the first party
so again uh Leslie from my perspective
I'd be happy with the consultation with
Rooney that's not an issue for me
I don't want the ties to a document that
is actually a government document and it
relates predominantly to the public
service
now whether that comes into the
discussion when we go to talk to arunaka
or anybody else that's fine but I think
that box isn't too far
to be French yet I think the more one
suit you write in that sentence the more
great divisive is going to be I mean I
would prefer just have a full stop after
that I'd I mean clearly it's going to
involve consultation with a for renuka
clearly it's gonna it's gonna include
thinking about the depina concrete paper
clearly it's also going to consider the
later paper that Evelyn referred to sure
um so I I think a full stop after
frankly just a full stop after a
bilingual approach
uh well and then consultation no problem
that is the option that was proposed by
the mayor um yeah
okay
so any further discussion on those two
um motions
there being none all right put the
motion all those in favor
anybody opposed yep
now that's for the voting public
carried
and as a final District councils we just
need to
um we need to formally accept the paper
that came from staff which is what's
referred to there is an 12.2
Mary Trish all those in favor Gary hi
thank you
I think it might be helpful to have a
five minute break now if you want to
because we've got a whole lot more work
to do
major lake item that we have to
acknowledge which is a minister of
finance and projects uh meeting held on
the 20th June thank you grant for
putting that up
we're down yeah Darren thank you
um
right the order
okay the first one we're gonna deal with
is the minutes of the meeting of the
bluff community board held on the 22nd
of May Grant thank you yeah Leslie again
thank you any discussion around there
being none all those in favor carried
uh minutes of the risk and Assurance
committee held on the 23rd of May Leslie
thank you yep there by default thinking
all those in favor I carried
amongst the extraordinary meeting of the
finance and projects committee held on
the 23rd of May Grant thank you yep
yes Darren thank you all those in favor
aye Kerry
minutes of the council meeting held on
the 23rd of May
Trish you've got a hand up yep you're on
the record thank you Trish Barry thank
you any discussion
yeah certainly so just 39 a board box
around the CCTV project
um
so we've got next steps but
have we got that project actually in
here and the pmo like have we got a
management plan around how are we
delivering that and time frames and that
sort of thing someone from yep so yeah I
might ask I might ask rainy to
contribute to that all Leslie both in
there just before I do I just want to
acknowledge that I do get a lot of
community feedback about the urgency of
getting those cctvs and that's come from
ICL and from the police as well so
Leslie you're on there like you or
ranging either I am but Aaron may have
defaulting to Aaron thank you
so it's on the infrastructure agenda
yeah yeah it's page 39.
yeah
yeah okay I'm just on the council
meetings
hold on 23rd of mate we've got a a mover
and a signal all those in favor Kerry
sorry
thank you for that Michael move the
infrastructure yeah thank you second no
no sorry um
so coming back to your issue Grant uh
Aaron
we spoke or the message at the last
meeting was around the fact that there
was a brief update given but I'd also
advised councilor pottinger that we
would bring a full report update on
exactly where the project was at and
timelines to the infrastructure
committee meeting
um in two weeks time okay right rangi
um
this morning
um after like I've had a lot of phone
calls from the public and I've I sent an
email to Russell Pearson who's who's
leading this and just requesting
do you have any further update on the
completion of the network design and
tendering for this phase of work
unfortunately the news that ICC is
putting a CCTV system and has people
asking for completion and use States
it's been nine months now involving the
process so far in June there has been 20
vehicle theft burnouts
public pressure is becoming very anxious
it is probably time that the
infrastructure committee
starts laying out a proper timeline for
what comes next okay so I've asked for
that this morning
as I said before I've had the police ask
me I've had the community Patrol to ask
me ICL have asked as well a lot of pity
crime going on around the city
painting as well for Aaron of through
the chair would it be reasonable that we
do get we are at that stage now we can
have a timeline
uh I will just need to definitely a
timeline it's just in terms of exactly
we think we're still narrowing down
exactly some of that that detail because
we're working through those network
issues
um but it will definitely will
definitely be coming back with
reasonable chunks of that timeline there
just may be some finer detail that we
can't include it's it's amazing it's
good that the public interest but
unfortunately the pre-show is is people
are wanting it like yesterday
unfortunately it's yeah but you've only
been raising it for six years
some context to that so last night the
bluff community board meeting
we raised the fact that you know we do
need CCT down there because if you look
at what's happening there on the point
with those windows being ah the the
glass here is being smashed that costs
about a hundred thousand dollars every
time that's done so you know and that's
just one example in a community where
it's actually costing a community until
we make them safe sure and so we've got
to have absolute urgency about getting
this delivered and also there's a bit of
credibility we've talked about it we've
proved it we've got to get it delivered
I think Aaron's got the message yeah
yeah so we also have on there as part of
our uh accepting this infrastructure
committee uh
set of minutes is a recommendation that
700 000 meat
um committed to the uh additional
alternative water supply
any discussion around that
I've got to hit that water supply we do
yeah yeah that's one of the things that
came out of the recent Expo on renewable
energy from some of the people that are
wanting to be in their Community by way
of Economic Development need to be able
to secure a water supply that doesn't
mean they get enough water it means that
there are security around the water
supply that we're not at risk with
ringtone yeah I'll move that way yep
thank you so you can repeat it yep all
those in favor all right Kerry thank you
moving on as we are
emergency well-being committee move
their receipt and second by Leslie thank
you any discussion
they're being none all those in favor
carried
foreign
of Code Practice for subversion land use
and development now this is a very long
document very long document but we have
had a workshop before on it not only
have we had a workshop but we've
actually had a hearing yeah yeah thank
you
so you would move the two motions
two motions well that we accept and the
and the code approach
thank you a signal for that oh Trish
thank you
any discussion about that yep
lengthy document that it is oh crap yes
just around the process and I said in
that as an observer and look I think it
was a really great process that we where
we actually engage with industry to get
their feedback and try and evolve a way
forward that works really well for them
but meets their needs and I think
you know we've got to take out of that
and we're seeing it on the 1225 project
around how we're tendering and
Contracting people to work with us
there's a real partnership approach
we've heard it here today and I think
we've got a lot wider into our business
and look at you know some of our
infrastructure projects for example
around here we look at our process to
try and get more engagement with the
industry prior to the awarding of the
contract so we can learn from them
because they're the experts and it came
through very clearly in that hearing
that these people were experts in this
field and the committee to their in the
hearing panel you know took on board
what they thought I think there's a
really good message and lesson and
opportunity in that for us in some other
parts of our governance in process thank
you
preparing that you and I no no okay and
we've got a mover and a signal all those
in favor
adoption of the
2023-24 annual plan
hi Trisha
thank you
stop welcome to YouTube
um so this paper brings forward the
annual plan for the next financial year
um building on all of the Preparatory
work that cancels undertaken
um
the key
points to know are the proposed rate
increase of 5.67 which is marginally
above that forecast at the time of the
last annual plan primarily as a result
of inflation and interest rate changes
which have had a combined effect about
across both the operational and capital
programs
um the annual plan report it's um
document rather itself outlines in
detail all the variations to year three
of the long-term plan noting those
changes within the capital program
particularly
but I think the key message to be taken
out is that um
based on the direction of this Council
the annual plan has worked to respond to
the cost of living Challenge and as such
um
there is some adjustments that have been
made within the area of the funding for
three Waters and that's the primary
change other than inflation and interest
rates
so just as a reflection of that two
things for me I guess
um the five point whatever it was
um was also impacted by the movement and
the minimum wage by government
so acknowledging that is that increase
that we had over the previous
um figure which we accept as five
percent it's good justification
uh and the credit to the uh people that
did the paperwork and the exercise
behind the scene which is the elt team
that we started out this journey with
about 20 at one stage and to be where
the position we're at is um
an excellent result when you consider
what other councils are putting up we
will be in the very very bottom cluster
of increases
and we've taken a little bit of um
Service delivery flag for some of the
stuff that we've had to trim back on but
that's a that's a good healthy process
by my wedding so thank you for that
any other discussions
Tom
well that's not a question I guess as a
comment chip I I I I do think that this
is a
excellent document I mean it's a huge
amount of work it's gone in to keep the
proposed rates increase to the level
that it is
um if we had gone any further we would
have been cutting muscle rather than
rather than fat
um but you know until both of the
working officers and I think in terms of
the worker we as a council I think we've
arrived at a probably the best place
that we could
yeah the comments team yeah
as you've said like six months ago we
were warned over six months ago that
would be an increase of 20 percent well
and you look at where we've cut it down
to and Tom said it you know I'd like to
congratulate uh the staff the chairman
of Finance staff put in a great effort
to get it down to an acceptable level
mainly for the elderly and the people
that don't have much income would be a
great relief to them when you're looking
around at other councils in the South
Island you know up into double Focus
again so a big thanks to our staff
thank you
oh sorry right yeah thanks dude just 110
on board box just went through spec to
the
um comment around increased income from
ICL
with their discussions last week
any decision
is that that is still how we've prepared
it on that
with that with that taking into account
okay so that we had it prepared before
that right okay
any further discussions
okay I've got three uh motions here
receive the report adopt the annual plan
and delegate to the acting group manager
financing
I'm sure it's the ability to make any
minor very minor
corrections to the annual plan is
required
all those oh sorry oh yeah I've got
Leslie and uh address thank you
um all those in favor carried
okay settling rates for the year twin
that's a bit must be a bit of a type
though is it 20 23 24. so now that we
have adopted the annual plan it's time
to set the rates for the 23 24 year so
this is the rates setting from one July
2023. that's very soon so it's very soon
um so this is a standard um it is a very
long resolution
and it will go over multiple Pages
because if we are required to set each
of the rates separately you can take it
as one but it will set out each of the
differential categories
and um I think this gives us that 5.67
across the board
and Chris
and other than that I have I can take
any questions almost a full
recommendations you'll move the four
four ones a second there yeah I think it
is just some questions for you Patricia
before we we move on that I wasn't here
at the last full council meeting but I
noticed that Rodney tribe raised
a long list of issues in relation to
rates the these rates
and I'm not sure where that actually
went to he was talking about dog rates
and and commercial water rates and other
things did we get to any position where
we went beyond just hearing what he had
to say
that was if I recall rightly in relation
to the hearings on the annual plan yeah
it was one of the submission teams
submissions on fees and charges yeah
so we did factor into account
potentially what he said or took into
account what he said
okay thank you
all right any further discussion
being none
um all those in favor all right
item 15 the long team plan
pre-engagement and process update
so um this paper
results
feedback gained through the
pre-engagement campaign and also provide
some update on the process itself
um the report forms a summary
of the issues raised during the
pre-engagement
um all of the types of pre-engagement
that were undertaken are noted on page
172 I'll just note that there are a few
um still to conclude we're still working
through engagement process with matawaka
and so the results of that Colorado will
be brought forward to Council in due
course and with age concern as well
um but you'll see that we had a broad
um range of connection with the
community and many of you were at some
all of those sessions this paper
provides a summary I think
um
in common with many of these types of
Engagement within the long-term plan
there are very broad range of issues
that are raised by the community all of
the feedback received is attached as an
appendix I've drawn out some of the main
themes into the report itself this is
really an opportunity for yourselves as
decision makers just to reflect on the
cholero that you've heard from the
community and the stage that we're at in
the process
um I would suggest with a few things in
mind we are now kind of moving into the
activity and budget setting stage of the
long-term plan so it's good I think to
have some of the themes that have been
brought forward by the community kind of
in your minds as we're moving through
that process
um it's a chance to reflect on the
extent to which there's you feel there's
any Divergence between what the
community is saying and what the
discussions around this table have been
and then thirdly to look for any but but
possibly things that have been entirely
missed by Council
so in that sort of reflection I I would
note a few
um opinions of myself I guess in having
been involved in many of those Coro I
think first of all when we were out and
about in the community at the stands at
various events my sense was that there
was quite a different energy compared to
a few years ago that there was a broad
feeling of positivity amongst the
community that particularly the city
center streets work and the work and
decisions that have been made around
project 1225 there's a censor they can
see that there's some
um progress being made by Council
there's a different tenor to the
conversation I think that also
um the very broad range of issues raised
by the community largely reflect the
conversation so you have been having
around the table some of those themes
that were drawn out that you can see in
the paper such as housing such as the
needs of Youth mental health issues
um
the cost of living are things that you
have discussed many times around the
table there will of course be different
areas of Reflection from the community
that you can draw out
um but I think it is really worth and
hopefully you will be able to take the
time just to look into a broad range of
feedback and and use that and utilize
that in your decision making going
forward there will of course be later in
the long term Prime process the formal
consultation stage where you'll present
the actual options to the community for
decision so this is is an interim
engagement the other things to note in
terms of the process so just proposing a
change in timing to the Strategic
projects Workshop that's to enable
um particularly the workflow within the
um
Urban play project to be a little bit
further along in order for that phasing
and budgeting conversation to happen
this report also provides some further
background information on community
engagement coming up on Surrey Park
grandstand and on the bluff active
Recreation precinct which was discussed
yesterday at the bluff community board
um also provides a recommendation for
you to consider again whether a
development contributions policy is a
useful
um step forward
um and finally just to note that the LT
pre-process is well on schedule I think
we're making really good progress in
terms of delivering key outcomes that as
ever of course do remain risks to
delivery of the process but I think that
they are all in hand at this stage happy
to take any questions
thanks Rhiannon look
um the workshops I thought were
fantastic and and the the feeling was
really good but
the the thing that's troubling me is
that we seem to be in tune with our
community
unfortunately central government that
doesn't seem to be in tune with us and
what I want to quote is from yesterday
we had a waste stamp meeting
and the MFE were online to do a
presentation on the impending compulsory
curbside collection of food scraps now
during our Workshop everyone was really
keen on getting back to Growing growing
stuff composting doing that and I
suggested that to the uh two gentlemen
from the mefe and they said no one no
one does that that you can't can't be
doing that you know and and I said that
there'd be a lot of rate payers who do
this who don't want to be paying a rate
for a collection that's something they
don't get and and so and their reason
was obviously to save the planet
um with their food scraps so
um I think we we're going to have to
have uh serious talks there because when
I look at the rate of 236 dollars per
household for
for the collections in their previous
item that is going to be and if we want
to do glass as well this is going to get
out of control a wee bit and so this
paper here tells us it's going to be
compulsory
and unfortunately it's not aligned with
what we want to do or our community
wants to do
yeah I sat in on that meeting as well I
found it very frustrating and we didn't
give much detail out on there's a lot of
dates in the future but not a lot of
traction going forward in some ways
oh Barry yeah as far as uh the meetings
we head in here uh the um
free engagement I think there was a lot
of talk about having uh
um public hubs like Community hubs
invercargill and
is there anything going to be done about
that or we just gotta
sort it out
so through you chair
um council at the time of the last long
term plan determined to support the
Saving Grace Project
um which was to the value of one hundred
thousand dollars
um I think that the topic of community
hubs desk has been coming up more
frequently as this report does draw out
you so you're absolutely right counselor
on that and I think that it will be a
topic of further consideration later in
the ltp process in relation to the
allocation of external funding
you know being quite public about the
fact that I think that as a council we
need to start thinking about further
investment in South City given that
they're dissoline
and if you if you've put aside the fact
that we got the museum underway and we
might have some work potentially for an
art gallery either I think before we
start doing a whole lot more in the
inner city we need to be casting our
eyes down south as well exactly
no just I'm further
into a saying
the waste collection and the desire for
some of us to have glass collection and
um waste you know um compostable waste
collection is it that we should also be
looking at discouraging everybody
putting out their yellow bin whether
they need to or not and things like that
because I've noticed myself if I make a
if I make a conscious effort I actually
only need to put it out
um perhaps once every six weeks and
maybe that's
that's how we schedule the um collection
that actually although we've got to buy
a you know the smaller bins for the
other materials which would be a cost
and they would have to be collected but
if we actually started looking at what
that takes out of what we put in the
other waste streams and whether we are
able to reduce
the number of times we collect our red
bin the number of times we do other
things perhaps that might equal out and
it's a bit of lateral thinking because I
think we want to be encouraging this
sort of planning in the long-term plan
um but again it's probably my personal
ambition to see us do waste differently
rather than the same old same old and
just add on and add on cost
encourage people to do things
differently
so I just might reflect on that everyone
I think you're quite right from my
observation our whole Waste Management
waste minimization area is a disaster at
the moment a rainy smoking away so he
doesn't normally agree with me on these
sort of thing but it's terrible it
really is when we're not coordinating
any shape before
we do have to get the glass out if we
leave the glass in one bin it interferes
with the it breaks up and Transit and
the phase of their ability to recycle we
put it in the other bin it just adds
weight to what goes over the wave Bridge
which just increases our costs so we
need to find a solution to that
to that waste nothing
Grant sorry yeah I agree we're in the
waist um a couple of three things just
to summarize for everyone
um Percy how many people do you think
we've engaged with
over the thing just as a rough geese
two thousand
I would say probably not
tooth not as many as two thousand
um I can't give you an exact number that
it it wasn't a quantitative engagement
on this yeah and congratulations to the
staff who got involved in it because um
it's pretty cool you know I know you're
passionate about it it's a really
important piece of what we do I think
there's three themes for me it's safety
and community
around particularly around the cameras
letting go he's fine
um Parks and Rec might be spy well
someone cleaned the windows oh that
sorry grant that was that was engineered
by Jonathan just to reinforce it we need
to seal the windows
it's all going to drop through in a few
minutes
how to take material there yeah
and the importance of parks and recs and
mental health I think that comes through
really really strongly and it's signal
to we need to get our Parks and Rec
strategy really robust and make that a
key to our long-term plan and then
Economic Development youth Council seem
a little bit confused about what that
might be but there's a number of times
that it's mentioned particularly in the
Raw feedback around you know the
affordability of things well the only
way through that is economic development
we can't do it through subsidy so we're
going to have to really push out into
those areas but but again Grant just as
a reflection because we've had a lot of
discussion around the economic
development that faces a city
um but it's it's it's hinged on on
housing and it's which is uh it's hinged
on the security of water not not
necessarily the volume and it's it's
hinged on the security of electricity as
well which is not the supply but the
longevity of it
um so these are
from what I've seen are quite complex
issues yeah it's a chicken and egg
situation you can't hit one without
without the other
so we've got some real work to do
my one's just really to go back to what
um in in Islam is Iran was sort of
referring to around the uh disposal of
wastage and things like that so
I suppose something that I didn't see in
this was probably around
what we had talked about earlier
and having a deep starting doing a stage
approach properly or doing something
rather than doing nothing around having
a Depot or somewhere that that people
could actually drop glass off
uh we had some discussion about the
waste now
one of one of the dilemmas we have is
that's commonly used in small
communities so the the district
represents were talking about that they
have large bins out because it's just
not cost effective to pick up
um because they get small amounts and
they have to cut them a long way so
there's all that carbon emission stuff
as well but we need to take wholesale
some of the stuff out it's really not
good for us so even if we got a third of
it out Randy will tell you some of the
pictures we've seen recently of what
comes into the recycling plant it's just
horrible
um and and the broken shards of glass it
doesn't take many glass to get above the
level that the uh the international
people just don't take our cardboard or
paper
well we're actually not doing nothing
unfortunately this is uh the glass
things because it's going to be an
increased level service that's going to
be included in the ltp and when it comes
to us it's going to come with costlings
for a bin system but it'll also come
with the opportunity for Alternatives
yeah yeah so that's that's the thing is
you look at the costs and go separate
Ben fortnightly pick up now
yeah and the same with other things here
so yeah and there was some potential at
that meeting that we might be able to
get the bins sourced through
a Ministry yeah that was a potential too
they mentioned that which was nice
yeah
um like
like so just to note that feedback on
waste amongst other environmental issues
from the community is on page 181 of the
um report in the appendix and also that
their next workshop on activities one of
those activities will be solid waste
where the opportunity to really discuss
all these issues in detail so it would
be helpful as we go forward into the
long-term plan if you can just prompt us
on
the feedback you've been getting in the
in this process as we go in because it's
very easy to forget what the committee
have said to us yep that'd be great can
do
any further discussion
great there's been none so we'd like to
move all six recommendations Barry
Lucy thank you all this in favor carried
the best to last
I would
welcome Hendrick
a very long feature for local government
report yes and I think I mean as as the
paper suggests this is very early on in
the piece and there's nothing that you
need to do immediately but it's
highlighting
and further developing our risk maturity
that a lot of these are have big
strategic implications and as through
these reforms going on not only do they
have strategic implications for yourself
but they have implications for staff
um which feeding the staff well-being
and we're seeing the impacts of that
with the continued sort of delay and
uncertainty around things like what is
now affordable Waters and so it's an
opportunity for Council to consider how
it wants to approach some of these
changes what it wants to try and do
whether it wants to try and be proactive
reactive what the headspace is like
obviously knowing that there is a great
deal of uncertainty around these things
um how we want to try and manage that
uncertainty to take advantage of what
may or may not occur I think it's also
quite useful that it feeds on from the
last paper that you had because I think
over the last few years Council has
whether knowingly or unknowingly
responded quite well to those changes
and so the increased emphasis around
well-being and and those items in the
current planning process reflect very
much the changing Focus
that he's coming through in this paper
around where Council should be focusing
their priorities and so to a certain
extent council is already pivoting the
way this paper would force you to go but
it's just how much you want to engage in
that how much you want to
sit back uh which bits you may want to
engage in it's just a matter of I can't
sort of consider yeah so give me some
feedback on that that's an opening
discussion my preference is for option
one to do nothing
and and the rationale for that is that
the report talks about A Five-Year Plan
implementation plan the first two years
are the government developing policy and
development
and I think for us to jump in ahead of
that would be unwise it creates work for
our staff and potentially for a staff
team as as or as your report says that
might be undone by other developments
that come down the track certainly do we
know what's happening in the election
would be a good thing to have
um
it talks about potential for five
unitary authorities
and at best that's a that's a southern
Authority but at worst it could be in
otago South Authority
um and if it was the larger of the two I
mean I just can't get my mind around how
we would have a council that covered
otago South
um
which is a really a population-based
type model where in fact we've got the
geographical issue of southern district
to to resolve as well and so I think
there's an awful lot of water to go
under the bridge yet I wouldn't be too
Keen to get too involved with that I am
certainly not to establish a team yet
my preference I guess which may not be
what you're looking for here is just to
leave this on the table to laugh the
election but and then come back to get a
clear picture on what we might want to
go to but I think
authentic regards which which government
we end up with I think both of them will
need a year or two to decide where they
want to go I guess
with this around Unity authorities or
other
um the other option they gave us was
which was a bit of an overarching and
overarching Council open above the
existing councils which I think would be
totally unworkable but
um
it was my preference
Tom
I mean I guess we're not here to talk
about the recommendations overall cheers
I'm I'm not going to get into that
um it's whether we should do anything
today and I agree with you of you that
you know if you don't know where you're
going in any road will take you there
yeah does it matter if we're always like
and and the reality is that we don't
know whether government would pick up
all of these recommendations or make a
smorgasbord government pick up some of
them and leave others behind and did
nothing I mean we just don't know so I I
I I think I'm in favor option one accept
that if you look at the
um if you look at the the actual uh
published material there is
recommendations in page 120 and 121
other of things that councils could get
on with doing now sure and when I read
those actually I think it's actually
quite a good list I think the other
things we're already doing by and large
yeah
um
a lot of them are things we'll do now so
I think it might be worth just sort of
mapping those recommendations against
things that we already have in plan are
things already good on their way because
I think it's a little a little good
stuff in that I think 12 recommendations
it was interesting when I talked to Jim
Palmer who was on more than one occasion
the chair of that review panel he told
me that the issue of amalgamation was
not one of the terms of reference from
government so when I hear people say oh
they've been very bold in their
recommendations I think they've just
jumped outside their terms of reference
the minister has been very clear that
nothing will be implemented before the
election nothing
um so we won't have a clear picture on
what they want going forward until at
least after the election and I'm not
sure given the fact that they didn't
have the in the terms of reference the
issue of amalgamation or unitary
authorities right whether he'd actually
he or she would actually have any
stomach for that anyway I'm not sure
[Music]
um
ever
during a stop take of where we're at
compared to the recommendations even
irrespective of whether
um these
these initiatives go forward because I
think it it reminds us where we are at
and sometimes we don't actually really
know we're at
in relation to what current thinking is
but I do think
um as having gone to one of the one of
the panel
um hoi is that
they've clearly gotten signals as
they've been out going around areas
about things like amalgamations and they
can see where the wind is going just as
well as any of the rest of us so I think
for us to say that they went outside
their Breeze that may have been what the
government or whoever said that they
should do but in actual fact the fact
that they saw that there was a need to
initiate the discussion and put it in a
document like this it's not necessarily
a bad thing I think we need to look at
all of these things as helping us grow
in our understanding and getting when
the time comes to make these and have
had conversations we're a bit better
informed and we've had a time to
actually
explore what all the options and what
all the pros and cons are and for that I
think this amount of provocative
thinking is probably not necessarily A
Bad Thing
so just as I've got your ring just as a
reflection on that
um one of the things that came out of
the local government conference recently
was regardless of what we want to do
which is what we've been prompted to
sort of get on the front foot at the end
of the day the call is made by the local
government Commission
um they've previously had councils
especially in the wairarap area four
small councils that wanted to combine
and twice had been knocked back by just
saying they don't agree with it um so us
doing too much front foot front foot
work at this stage I guess is a bit of
an issue ringy
um
this is my opinion in it so we've got
different to any of the recommendations
you've got there I thought the report
was very superficial and failed to
address really the elephant in the room
which is the vast Gap between the
current localism versus centralism in
this country and that's what that does
it creates the imbalance of
responsibility and access to taxpayer
funding the late Dave Cole was trying to
remedy this but unfortunately passed
away
I mean the the document touches briefly
on a better collaboration between local
and central government than setting up
at believe this or not setting up a new
government Department to take care of
this I mean that's well there's got to
be a bill and Dia uh we just need a new
Department to tell us the time that's
fantastic what the report needed to do
was to expand its scope
and actually look at the governance
roles of both Central and local
government and then establish what the
best balance is and you know it's like I
can't believe central government is sort
of sitting there doing this it's like I
I guess a turkey is never going to ask
for an early Christmas you know so they
they won't want to review their own nest
and that's the problem is that you know
we've got a country of 5 million
and looked a bit of governance structure
so that the money can be spread out Nick
three Waters is a problem that was
created by
centralism versus localism no money so
that created the problem so my option
would be and since people said it's
early in the piece is to write for them
and say do it again
politely yeah yeah it's an interesting
issue that you raise uh I asked Jim
Palmer again
over a coffee without gaining him too
much you know what was driving this
centralization versus decentralization
and
um why was the government and it's it's
not specific to labor I think it's just
the government whoever the governor are
not keen to get into
um these larger Unity of councils
potentially 15 or 20 and like he
wouldn't tell me but also I told him and
he was allowed to smile if I got it
right I said well if you had 15
super councils and in New Zealand why we
do need 60 electric MPS
and he said yep got right on the button
so I guess there's some water to go
under the bridge yet I guess that Grant
I think was next on the
yeah thanks Chad just firstly
um cancer podger on sort of I don't know
whether I'm surprised and Confused that
you'd think anything really really
poignant would come out of central
government or this sort of paper so
don't hold it too much I've been saying
that I think Tom's suggestion around
um adopting those 12 points is a
reflection point for us to compare a
long-term plan I think stock check was a
word that Evelyn used that's probably
better actually yeah we'll stop taking
um in our support you know option 2A we
don't do anything except those bullet
points to reflect on what we're well
we've got any plans
and I suppose just to address that
actually I think where we were thinking
in terms of to being it's it's not not
go out and change what we're doing but
have a look at where we are what if if
this was enacted what would we need to
change what would be inconsistent with
those changes that we might be doing
just so it's highlighted in flag so that
not that we change anything so we're
aware okay you've taken this path if
these reforms come in place that path
will have to change
that's really what we're doing and that
that encompasses those 12 steps because
that's the sort of things that we've
been looking at
crash with three Waters we saw the
amount of effort that took for staff to
get to present and then to have it hang
um I would be loath to ask staff to put
any effort into this I would rather that
they got the new Museum art gallery sust
or something I think something that you
know I hate to see their time wasted on
the well not wasted but spent on this
when we could do it on something else it
was more relevant to where we're at
so just point point of clarification for
me Andrew so between options one and two
if there was a desire from elected
members to do nothing but do a a stock
take as everyone said would that come
under one or two I would put that under
two that's the sort of thing that we
were anticipating with two yeah okay
where are we sitting what's it saying
okay if you're going to pray
okay any further discussion yeah so just
to clarify so doing nothing except using
this is using that page 322 is a stock
take for us to reflect on yeah
versus you know into Treasure's point I
think it's a well-made point you know
asking staff to come back with a report
which is going to take their resource
and effort sure you know
in my view it's pretty clear we're going
to do nothing except use that as a stock
take page to be able to reflect them
with things so we don't need any more
reports won't waste any more stuff time
at this point yep
so just
flitching there a little bit so what
you're saying is we do nothing but
acknowledge that
that the pages you're quoting as our
current position
I mean as we think about those 12 things
on that page
um I think it would be
appropriate to at least you know make a
few notes about where we sit against
them and whether you call that a
reporter no I don't know and we don't
want to you know give a busy on and more
work it doesn't seem to me that if you
look at the ltp and work in hand you
know you you'd be fairly easy I think
Rihanna to say yep you can take that box
we can take that book because I mean you
haven't already done enough in that area
I think it'd be whilst in a stock check
to that extent and up probably would
result in a report of sort but we're not
talking about a huge document we're
talking about our page you know all
right well I think if you could take
Andrew's cell phone I think we we could
probably get him to do it
I was just going to say I'm inclined to
to think that doing absolutely nothing
is not
quite what we want to do so I'm I am
quite inclined to say we should do a
perhaps lighter than we would normally
do to be
um to at least
at least have some reflection bearing in
mind that we don't want to overload
stuff but it just seems not the best
idea to completely leave it as a Do-Nut
I I can give you some comfort we're not
looking for work
um it would only if if we had time we
could have done a high level report for
this but we just didn't have time at
home and this was released yeah we
thought it was important that it be on
the table
um it will not be extensive so Rihanna
could do it over a weekend he's
suggesting yeah
look the way we're talking here is I
mean it sounds to me like everybody's
talking about the option of doing
nothing
and that other thing is just a measuring
thing then it's just business as usual
because we're already doing those things
so there's no required I'd be thinking
just carry on as we are and do auction
won't do nothing because we're already
doing some of those things that we're
mirroring again but this is what we do
we're not doing it for any particular
purpose that's just what we do so why
would we change what we do if we're
doing that we're doing okay but maybe
identify the gaps and maybe you see well
we'll get 10 books he's covered but
we've done nothing in these two areas
yeah I think that'd be worth it but we
don't know what's going to happen
seriously we don't go after October
and then it's going to take a year or
two like obviously okay so I'll make it
easy for the for the voting purposes
when we get to two they'll just put up
option two and Andrew's heard the
message about a very very lightweight
reflection of what's happening on on
those on that page you refer to
um and we'll just see how the vote goes
on it so um I'll move uh recommendation
or somebody can move recommendations one
three and four Barry
Darren thank you all those a favor in
relation to two
um yes sorry about it yes receiving that
I reckon the report substandard so I'm
actually voting against okay I will have
that recorded thank you ring
um
and
um and in all in in relation to number
two uh I'll put up I'll put up the
motion for uh option two a second
sorry yeah
um
all those in favor of 2B
hi yeah those opposed
one two
only uh two B is carried
or not to be careful not to be like that
recorded
you escaped likely Andrew
all right anything else
don't do it again
okay the last one in in public is this
draft statement of intent for the
Southern Museum and art gallery
carry everybody as you know if yeah we
have to do a statement of intent for all
of our ccos this is the very last one
for the um settler Museum and art
gallery trust board Incorporated
um if it was adopted so it was initially
proposed and then we were through the
paper when we identified that there are
a number of deficiencies in the
statement of intent itself so have taken
that opportunity to reflect it and
actually try and make it something
that's useful for the incoming Trustees
of the trust board
um there are
kind of two recommendations there and
one of them is simply to ask the board
that it confirms the draft statement
attempt meets its requirements for
non-financial performance targets that's
a standard request of all ccos
um outside of that happy to take any
questions or other directions
you know why yes thanks for hanging move
the two recommendations yep thank you
Leslie
um any discussion
not being none do you want to get away
and Tom do you sorted to think so it's
okay okay the dog was getting an
operation though yeah excellent yeah so
no discussion around around that
um I'll put that into the motion all
those in favor carried
sorry he lied to me
the minutes of the uh finance and
produce committee dated the 20th of June
thank you grant
Alan thinking
all right and it has two parts to it
to pass it
um all those will favor all right
carried
so we now need to move into public
excluded yeah I'll move take it red that
you've you've uh thank you Leslie take
it read that you've seen all the reasons
for going in
all right indeed
live streaming gone
going